okay a lot of people have been waiting
for this one I did reappear on the Jesse
Lee Peterson show in person this was
actually his TV only version TV only
show called the fallen state not the
Jesse Lee Peterson radio show of which
I've been kicked off before and it was a
very interesting appearance and I think
people who follow me understand that the
attitude I took was this entire thing is
really not super serious and it was sort
of I took a I took a distant approach in
that my priority was not to get too
worked up by the things that Jesse Lee
Peterson said most of which made
absolutely no sense
there's also we're gonna keep in the
edit before they went live for some
reason the camera cut to us just
awkwardly sitting on the stage and it
went out on air during his live stream
and then his intro started and it is a
very very awkward moment this is the
entire thing uncut my interview on the
fallen state with Jesse Lee Peterson we
are amazing
welcome to to the Father State YouTube
live I'm Justin E Peterson apologize for
the late start but we are black and
black people are late we start on CP
time
it is midterm election season and I have
with me David Pakman he is the
progressive host of the political
television radio program the David
Pakman show
David thank you for coming I can't
believe I'm here I know it's amazing
last time we didn't end well I remember
right do you remember I remember I had
to kick you off my show you kicked me
off you said I never have that idiot
back on my show you call me a girlie man
yeah what changed your mind about having
me back after the ban that's really my
producer oh you didn't even want me here
no I want you you oh you did I told you
I I'm glad you're here oh just because I
fight with you doesn't mean I don't love
you okay yeah you love me I don't really
know you do you have to know me to love
me I
have a general love for all people but I
don't know you but do you need to know
me to love me not as a human now why not
and I'm saying I don't need to know you
to all of you it's part of the human
race yeah well I love you thank you
are you surprised not really were you
surprised it after we off to radio show
not really
and you didn't seem pleased with my
answers oh you were not answering that's
what it was was ask you a question I
will ask you where you're going you tell
me where you've been and so you can't
really do bring forth a good show that
way but sometimes you will admit a
question can be sort of it's like when
did you stop beating your wife right
like not every question is fair I don't
maybe well maybe you beat your wife I
don't know but and that would be an
example beat your wife I'm not married
oh yeah well wait until you get mad okay
Oh
so David what what I wanted to talk to
you about I want to talk about politics
I want to get to know you a little
better let's do it and so my first point
are you a Christian no you know do you
believe in God I don't are you an
atheist I I have an absence of belief in
God if you want to call that atheism it
could be agnosticism I'm not really sure
but I have an absence of belief in God
but it's not like I'm not going around
telling people God doesn't exist it's
sort of like if we heard a noise in the
back right now
I wouldn't say to you that was probably
an invisible purple hippopotamus I have
no evidence that that's what it is I
would say it's probably a noise caused
by something we've seen something we can
prove something there's evidence for I
wouldn't tell you
invisible purpose purple hippopotamuses
don't exist or could never exist right I
just have no reason to think that that's
what caused the noise have you always
not believing that have you ever
believed you know when I was younger so
culturally and ethnically I'm Jewish so
I was around a lot of Jewish people
growing up so there were Old Testaments
around and I would I would look at them
and you know I was sort of I was kind of
a blank slate in the sense that my
parents never imposed religious beliefs
on me but they also didn't tell me you
shouldn't believe anything it was sort
of open you know I could look at the Old
Testament
listen talk to people so there was a
period you know I'm still open to the
possibility of there being a god and and
I always sort of have been but that's I
don't currently believe that there is
one so I believe everyday you apart
Jewish and part Argentinian well they're
two different things so I was born in
Argentina my family a lot of a lot of
Jews from Eastern Europe before and
after the Holocaust moved out of Eastern
Europe as I'm sure you know Argentina is
one of the places that they went so my
family is is so I'm Jewish right but my
family was in Argentina so like I grew
up speaking Spanish and and in that
sense I'm sort of of Hispanic culture
yeah okay and I know you are progressive
right not a liberal I don't really know
the difference at this corner is there a
difference you know a lot of this stuff
is just semantics I think it's better
you know I could tell you what my views
are on any particular issue but whether
I'm you know progressive or liberal or I
don't know I don't know what we gain
from talking would you consider yourself
progressive I want to see progress so in
that sense but by the dictionary
definition I guess so the problem is
that there might be you might have some
ideas about what is implied by the
political term progressive that maybe I
agree with maybe I don't but I
definitely want to see you know humanity
progress for sure and one of the reasons
I'm concerned about you being a
progressive
is that and he specifically are all
progressive all men men only men only
men progressive women don't concern it's
normal
normal abnormal for women to be
progressive interesting Oh a liberal but
it's abnormal for a man to be a liberal
or progressive it's a sign of being a
beta male I didn't know how real men are
conservative Republicans you know and
strong in nature so I'm concerned if you
a liver or progressive well if I became
conservative would I no longer be beta
you'd become alpha well something to
think about
yeah how did you become a liberal
laughs regret progressive were you
always that way or did something happen
along the way
no interestingly you know I'm glad you
asked that actually in in high school I
took a lot of sort of standard what we
would call ex classical economics and
classical economics is pretty
conservative in a lot of ways you know
it assumes rational actors participating
in the akai is it assumes a lot of stuff
that that's sort of right now more
conservative in terms of economics so I
had a lot of those ideas and I thought
that they made sense and then I learned
more about behavioral economics and the
work of people like Daniel Kahneman and
others who say you know economics as we
usually teach it is is not right and so
that made me question the beliefs that I
had sort of assembled over time and then
I was questioning all of my beliefs so I
definitely have had it sort of a shift
to the left I was never a right winger
yeah I'm not saying that yeah but I've
definitely moved to the left that the
more I've become educated about issues
this is why I'm not there to allow
children to go to public schools mmm
tell me more
because they are brainwashing them and I
didn't go to public school turning them
away from their values I didn't go to
private school - if you don't watch out
for it I'm kidding I did go to hell yeah
do your parents know that just education
system had its impact on you turned you
into a liberal do they know that it had
this impact on you know it's interesting
I mean they know my political views are
you later and are they happy with them
do they're very they're very I don't
know my mom is the happiest Jewish mom
you could imagine so you're not been
married you have you're not married or
never been married no kids and all that
I've never been married that's true I'm
not currently married of course and I
don't have children at this time yeah do
your date I do and do you find that it's
difficult for young men merely your age
group to find good women to date not at
all no no no no the women that you dated
have data are they controlling how do I
do date women exclusively but I'm how
did you know that I date women it's
possible I date men or both right when
area is possible but I wouldn't assume
that about didn't assume that that yeah
I'll let you tell me now you date men to
exclusively women Oh
would it be a bad thing for our
conversation if I dated men I wouldn't
be bad for our conversation would be
interesting okay why don't you date men
I'm not attracted to men oh good I don't
see anything wrong with it but I know
you do you do not see anything wrong
with it with being attracted to men why
not why would it be wrong because it's
of the same sex so is that normal but
that's not an argument it's a fact what
makes something normal let me ask you
this I wanted to ask you this too I
wanted to ask this not my regular self
please if a woman decide that oh you
know I feel like a man and I want to be
a man and she goes to a doctor
rushed out of the road to a doctor's
office yep he take off her female body
parts and attached male body parts to
them well to her would that make her a
male would it make her male uh-huh or
would it make her a man either one
depends how you define either right
right would it make her a man or me a
male would she still be a woman with
body parts of a man I mean it'd be a
transgender man but would it be a woman
would be what make her a man it would be
a transgender man does that mean it
means it's someone who was born
biologically female wouldn't it right
this isn't my area of expertise I'm just
I'm interested although people want you
know right from wrong will you see it
right do I know right from wrong I don't
know do I
you don't know if you know right from
wrong I think people want to know what's
right and what's wrong but does every if
everybody knew right from wrong no bad
things would ever happen right well how
about you do you know right from wrong I
feel like I do and so if you saw if you
knew a female who took off her body
female body parts and attached a male
body parts to them what you think wow
that's a man or would you still know
that's a woman it depends on the person
right I depend how what they look like
and and sort of how they exist how about
a woman that you knew you know very well
yeah David you're not a good friend
today I'm gonna become a man okay I'm
going down to the doctor's office and
have some male body parts or tasks right
would you still think would you state
that your friend is a woman or a man I
mean my reaction would be radical
empathy I would say Oh
that's a major change she's like what
what's going on that's making you want
to do that and I would listen to them
yeah
with empathy well would you know a woman
on what you think it's a man we think
it's gonna be hard to say I mean every
person is different right I'm talking
about you know I mean every other person
every other person I don't know what
they what they would be like what it
would be like to be with them but what
would you think I don't I would still
know that that's a woman right I don't
care how great a male body parties
attack right it's still a woman okay but
what you could fit it might be a man
what do you think of it as a man it what
I think of it as a man right it's a
person right I don't say right it's a
female but would you think of the female
as a man we'd have to meet and see what
it's like you already know you grew up
with it here's the girlfriend right but
this is imaginary would you think it's a
man or woman I have no idea amazing you
don't believe in God where do you get
your values from where do I get my
values yeah culture family science I
wanted to ask you about cap let me first
a do you have anything to ask me any
questions you think you disagree with me
about what I love course we disagree but
like what do you disagree with me about
what do we agree about I don't know that
we agree on anything my wife for example
economics social issues gay marriage I
don't know do we agree about anything
well we don't yeah
so I want to ask you about judge
Cavanaugh okay
when the children of the lie tried to
take his life I'm not familiar with them
the children are allowed at liberal
media the Democratic Party the Rhino
Republicans they're never propers
okay there's no like everybody but Trump
movement those evil women has to have
movement all civil rights leaders all of
us they are children of the lines a lot
of people it is I think have a lot a big
family but when they tried to destroy
him that woman whatever her name is
it won't come to me doesn't matter to
you anyway right I mean yeah when she
lied on him and you saw that the
children of the large fire to destroy
these
here's why Eddie's children okay my
accusing him of being a rapist and all
that calling him a rapist were you
disappointed to see the children of
Allah act in that way so this is one of
those questions where the framing of the
question we have to talk about because
you're assuming that I already believe
she lied but I don't know that she lied
I don't have any evidence that she lied
did you pay attention to here I watched
every minute did you hear anything to
indicate if she was telling the truth
yes right there was no so here's a
couple things I'll tell you what to me
suggested she was telling the truth
number one it was all downside for her
coming forward there was no upside she's
not gonna get any money now because she
made the allegation she's not gonna live
a better life she had to move so first
of all it's sort of like motive there
was no upside to her there was the
chance that maybe it would prevent
Kavanaugh from being confirmed but most
people including me all along were
saying this isn't going to stop his
confirmation so that was one thing that
made me not doubt her that there was
really nothing again the second thing is
during the hearing which was like what
ten hours long it was very very long
like five hours each of them there were
like dozens of questions that Brett
Kavanaugh didn't answer and she answered
every question and when I see that and I
see one person answering every single
question and the other person not
answering so many questions based on my
experience talking to people who
sometimes lie and sometimes tell the
truth I believe that it's more likely
the person not answering the questions
is the person lying amazing yeah so she
was at weird where and how I don't know
where it happened I don't know when it
happened I remember as a beer and then
she developed this little weak little
girl voice is supposed to be a professor
and if you develop this little little
one name let's Christine blatant bored
right so let me see if I knew develop
this forth little girl tone her voice
made you not trust her know her line
made me she had no proof but everybody
mentioned she doesn't remember when
where or how only thing she remember is
a beer that's not until you remembered a
lot of stuff you would have known want
to believe her not to see that he would
lie and plushies now I know mentally off
you know what like the life was all
about nobody was home you're making
assessments of who's mentally off on TV
you think mentally are and that's your
assessment yeah because he was weird she
was weird yeah it's like they went to
the gates of Hell over to Israel
Kavanagh seemed normal to you over in
Israel there is a little old CD now
where the gates of hell is there and
it's a dark pit that if you go down and
you can't return they say and so
whenever I see women like that and men
like that it reminds me men and women
like what like for just wicked lion it's
a woman was willing to destroy this man
because he didn't agree with his
politics she would being used I believe
how she Kara out there I think that I'm
pretty sure she was a she was a
Republican I don't know what politics
can I ask you a question decide I want I
want to understand but what could she
have done during the hearing where you
would have said you know what I do
believe her like what could she have I
know you don't believe her right right
like the way it went down you don't
believe her
what could she have done during the
hearings where you would have said I
believe her if she has she gone Nerdist
saying you know what the children of the
lab trying to use me to destroy Josh
Kavanagh but that would be a lie I see
no reason this man should be destroyed
and so I just want you to know not to
trust the children of the lie so only if
she would can said you would have
thought I would have I want to believe
that oh yeah she brought real evidence
he brought none logo and but that's how
evil the children on the left are they
will destroy you to get what they want
and that's power and well I'm curious if
they're so powerful the children of the
law they're not powerful
oh I think that's what they want I think
we will destroy it they will they will
destroy you they'll try to destroy okay
to get power and do you agree with that
no no really
do you trust the would you want someone
to Boston to accuse you and now you and
the world has to believe the accuser and
not believe you or would you rather be
its
in a sense yeah improving there's two
different things right in our justice
system in our legal system we have
innocence until guilt has improved
there's no question about that what
happened with dr. Christine Blasi Ford
was not it was not part of the justice
system right this was people like you
and me and hundred senators and the
public making an assessment of the
believability of two different people
right so nobody I would say to you
innocence until guilt has been proven is
logical if you're looking at putting
someone in prison but this wasn't a
criminal trial you and you acknowledge
that right that's so ridiculous I don't
know it's just true it's interesting how
when your children are real I know but
saying it's ridiculous is ridiculous
it's not an argument
this man was accused I don't care if it
was an innocent man walking down the
road you don't just accuse people and
whatever reason gonna make up for it
doesn't make sense this woman here
accused this man right what no proof and
the children of the large fire to
destroy him oh come on no proof okay
would you want to be falsely accused
before any reason at all whether for
jobs course not right
you want any and if someone should
accuse you yeah when you want to hear to
assume you in if you're innocent I would
want the legal system so you wouldn't
mind if it's not if it's somewhere not
the legal system people have tried to
prove a point this is I'm sure you're
gonna denounce this because of your
strong position against false
allegations because of my position that
Christine Blasi Ford seemed credible to
me people actually started contacting
local media claiming I raped them
because they said David we're gonna show
you how easy it is to get people in
trouble with false rape allegations from
men and they started doing it and you
know what the the allegations were so
obviously not credible that they didn't
go anywhere because obviously false
allegations don't go anywhere
well they tell you right now you're not
a value to them you can't hurt them so
it meant nothing but I mean put yourself
in a position such as just Cavanaugh or
let's get up say did you get some
influence where you can influence people
in a way I won't change for you man you
know I asked you did you date girls and
you say
why would you assume I date it's
interesting that you assumed that yeah
should I assume you date boys no oh
because it's normal to assume you date
girls or otherwise statistically
speaking you're right yeah most people
are heterosexual so was I wrong for so
me you date girl I'm not at all offended
now okay I just found it interesting but
it's interesting that a straight man
would mate back no agree that up the
reason was you've called me a girly man
so many times a week oh okay that's
because it's not because I think you
that I'm gay right got it
glad we clarified Oh what do you think
of this so talk so call hashtag me to
movement in what sense we support it
well I support distilling coming out and
saying if something has happened to you
that's what I support really yeah but do
you so you don't support the entire
movement I don't know what the but the
bounds of the movement are I mean to the
extent that the idea of the movement is
you know a lot of people are sexually
assaulted and raped and they don't come
forward and the reason I mean it you
don't believe that that's a made-up lie
- oh who made that up
the children are - laughs I shouldn't
yeah they made that up because if you
notice they say things over and over and
over and over and over again and if
you're not paying attention you find
yourself believing in it well we really
really do research you find out is not
true like they would claim it at one
time that there were our rape on college
campuses was out of control right we now
found out that was a lie and so I did
wear my net it was a lot research had
proven it I don't have it with me but
there's no rape on campus not it's not
out of control in a manner that they
pretended that how do you define out of
control oh it's not happening in two
numbers that they say what numbers did
you know the lie I don't have numbers
but the children of the life say that
because they want to deceive you and
then he bring in all this emotion oh I
was 30 years ago walking down the road
and a man raped me so you don't have any
numbers or the study no it's not it yeah
yet because another thing too if you
notice it it doesn't make sense then
they go public with that anyway it's not
make their lives better this is a
different art you know only thing you're
gonna do it hurt man Tony's women'll I
in isn't that an argument that would
suggest that they're telling like you
just said it's not gonna make their
lives better to go public isn't that why
we should say wait a second
Christine Blasi Ford a college campus
rape victim it's not going to make their
lives better so they probably are
telling the truth no they're doing it
because they hate men
oh and they especially hate street white
conservative Christian amount of power
mmm because it's the straight white
conservative Christian man who's holding
in country together oh if it wasn't for
them America would be associated a
society already it would be what a
socialist society
how would it become socially if you see
if you notice the average black man has
no authority no power the Mexican
doesn't have anything is that white
straight conservative Christian man that
is preventing them from turning this
country and she was you know a socialist
aside but so here let me ask you about
this I'm not a socialist myself I'm a
social depth just to be clear I'm not
advocating for social her I don't know
that many actual socialists like who
would who wears the big desire for the
u.s. to become socialist if you look at
your Democratic Party it is almost no so
she's in the demo she is Communist Party
now is one that's one socialist idea
from the Democratic socialized
healthcare no that's a social democracy
program no socialist and if you notice
that Barack Obama the Father Messiah you
know he's the father Messiah right I
don't know anything about that well a
bit mama Michelle he tried to turn
America into a socialist society it's
one example of a socialist policy that
he had socialized health care he didn't
do that for profit Obama taking care of
everybody how so by getting rid of jobs
many people mostly took care of people
by the way the field time jobs and they
had to work two part-time jobs in order
to survive Justin you don't even
understand the talking points rest stop
working and just went and dependent on
every line under government free Obama
phones
that's socialism your tell so how can
you solve a socially I want to ask a
real question I'm asking your real
question
Obama phones are not socialism now well
that's a good question let me ask you
real it is I really want to know this
the arguments against places like
Venezuela and Cuba and other so-called
socialist countries are that no one has
anything no one can afford anything
there is no technology there's no food
but you're saying that cellphones for
people or socialism yeah is that that's
your argument
yeah that's an example of it um so I
want to move on but I want to ask you
are you saying that you do not support
hashtag movement the has that movement
wanted to possess I don't I'm not really
part of any of these Twitter movements
or if the movement is about empowering
victims to tell people what happened I
support that but you don't support the
movement itself I don't know what the
lines of the movement are you have to
define it for me
um do you agree with me that men should
come out and just say matter that these
even women are doing and report women
become more women are raping young boys
teenage boys then men are with women let
me deal with the first part of the
question because I don't know about
those statistics but if your question is
should men come forward if they've been
yeah absolutely yeah of course we should
turn this on these women so these women
can see what it's like well it's not
that would be vindictive and that as a
man of God I don't think you would you
would suggest the revenge and
vindictiveness in that way no just go be
angry or just tell the truth but just
use the laws against them as well
well I would because not requiring and
women to tell the truth while we
required a manager know they are women
are every victim if they don't tell the
truth and in fact it just happened there
was a woman on a college campus who made
a false rape allegation she's going to
prison because there are laws again that
is good there are laws against that it's
rare but it does happen so you do a
green and emission use those same laws
to go after them no I believe that men
should tell the truth and if they've
been assaulted by anybody they should
tell but if they accuse a woman they
should not have to prove it they here to
be asked why you're doing this no in a
court he believed this is because they
said it now you might about we agree
that we should believe we should trust
and verify all of you
so you're not funniest thing about a
woman kind of qu and she should not be
disbelief believed I am for trust but
verify right but don't believe it just
because you theory the legal systems got
to investigate if it turns out she lied
of course there should be consequences
but I'm asking you should we believe it
just because they said it we shouldn't
disbelieve it because it's such a big
thing to come forward and make such an
allegation if we're gonna put anybody in
prison we need to we need a trial we
need an investigation for sure no matter
who the accuser is no matter who the
victim is and so should they be believed
just because they said it they shouldn't
be written off should they be believed
just because they fear it they should
and then we do an investigation and it
turns out they because they said it we
how would you start an investigation if
you don't believe them let me imagine
this for a second you're a police
officer I come in and I say someone has
raped me if you don't believe me at all
you don't even investigate right so as
the officer you should say this is
someone who has decided to come down and
tell me that this happened I am now
going to investigate it you have to have
some degree of plausibility in the claim
to even say let's do an investigation
this is a real problem police officer
yeah I'm not going to assume by the way
I'm gonna take you information in it
check it out to see if it's you're gonna
check it out but if you didn't believe
you wouldn't be sure we believe the
women just because they said it it's a
false framing of the question when you
say I would trust them and I would
verify you're not answering a question
that's the answer but I don't like the
answer you don't understand a question I
think I understand it when what is it
about the question that's difficult for
you it's the framing of it because
believe means what I'm not saying on her
say-so we put somebody in prison all
right if you're asking me that no that's
not what I'm asking I would believe it
enough to investigate it do you would
you gave it
Patman believe it just because she said
I liked how you had to check what like
my last name was there I would believe
it enough to investigate it yeah give me
just a yes I'm black and slow so give me
a simple yes or no would you believe it
just because they said it
how else would you find out about it if
they didn't say that answering question
is greater than watching right now I
hope so and you know why shouldn´t
because they thought you gonna keep my
butt so you got to live up to it I found
out this was a debate today would you
believe it because I fan it I I would
believe it because the only way we're
gonna learn about it is if they say it
and then I'd invested believe yeah okay
I want to ask you about anything you
have for me any questions okay
the I do have one are these really the
most important topics for you absolutely
okay how are there others that are more
important for you yeah our economic
system wealth inequality health care of
your politics nuclear disarmament
climate change we thought to get to
degree who I hope so I'm getting to that
all right I got actually just kept Colin
Kapernick mm-hmm I see him as a thug and
all of the other players who are
kneeling during the national anthem that
they are turning their backs on the flag
on the country men and women of the
military the fans and I think they all
should be fire and got in throw toes sob
ease out right do you agree with that I
don't and why well I don't believe that
anybody should be able to tell private
businesses that aren't breaking the law
how they need to do employee relations
right so if I were to come in here and
say I don't know what kind of you know
fiduciary relationship you have to the
people in this room maybe maybe their
employees if I were the government and
you weren't doing anything illegal with
them and I said you got to fire these
two and I got two other other people you
have your a private business you can do
as long as you're not breaking the law
you can do whatever you want so I don't
know of any legal basis on which the NFL
or that it's really the team's
individually that are the employers I
don't know how we justify having them
fire players I mean it doesn't do we the
taxpayer give money to other MBA I
thought we were talking about football
right doesn't even matter right this is
just trying to get this point on the
record yeah do we go mine into them
there as consumers or as taxpayers well
there are some stadiums that are built
with taxpayer money
in exchange for the amount of biz tax
revenue that they bring to the site and
so is that government environment it's
government involvement yeah and so
shouldn't the government has to have
something to say about it no because you
wouldn't apply that's not any other
business it's not one of us that private
owned so we do have something to say
about it right can I give you a counter
we there is not and I'll tell you why if
you allow me if you have a private
business and you pay into the state's
unemployment insurance the government is
now involved with your business does
that mean they can come in and tell you
what to do no but if I'm paying into it
well my business is pay into the
impermanence I'm a taxpayer my money is
going to the government and into me and
giving today yeah football teams are all
Association right so I have something to
say about it this is my argument I'm
just telling you that's not the way it
works legal let's go back to that though
so you don't think it's wrong to turn
your back on the country that because if
it wasn't for football there would be no
common cabinet and most of these black
players they'll be rats
there'll be thugs they'll be in jail and
so it's not a good turn why do we have
to put up with these thoughts you don't
have to that's you can say I'm not gonna
go to any more football games no they
shouldn't be there's no legal basis
stops important that's up to the fans
would you recommend that no you're not
and why not I just don't see why anyone
would do that
it's are you happy with nay I'm doing
this you think he's okay I support the
First Amendment in free speech but not
at work sure you can't do that at work
the the teams might do that at work I
will fire them so fast like the hare but
that's your call if that's in your
employee hand but should they do that
it's up to the teams okay I gotta ask
you about Kanye West what do you think
about Kanye West his relationship with
the president and all the things that
are happening around him right now I've
never liked his music I think he has
significant mental illness it appears
that he's off his medicine and I've
never heard him say anything
particularly interesting
so you see him no way I see Ford
Kristine Ford I'm not sure though she
loved her medication at home too I
wouldn't be able to say yeah but how can
you Casey he's mentally are appears to
be mentally are but he's neither Kanye
West's mentally
didn't see it that way why not that's my
purse what has he done to give you that
impression
oh his I mean did you see the video of
him in the Oval Office
yes I'm not a mental health professional
but the mental health professionals I've
spoken to including many in my family
identified that he seemed manic bipolar
and generally off and he did say at some
point I think he said something about
being off his medication so I think it's
pretty widely established what did he do
to imply that those things I just told
you right you think theme that well what
was he doing to employment again his
manic nature his inability to sort of
sit still have a normal conversation
swearing in the Oval Office looking
around very anxiously nervously saying
things that don't make sense saying
slavery was a choice I mean would Phil
you thought that slavery was a choice it
was a dough Mason comment I thought it
was inaccurate really why because
slavery is not a choice amazing do you
agree with him that he as a black man
and but I people should be free thinkers
of course should not be on the
plantation of the Democratic Party
I disagree with that verbal wall with
the okey doke I regardless of the race
of people they should be free thinkers
right and so you agree with him when you
say that I don't agree with the
characterization about plantations what
because I just think it's nonsense but I
do agree that everybody regardless of
race should be a free thinker and so
black people not all not or not all but
most have been on the plantation for
over 40 or 50 years now what do you mean
out of the Democratic Party and they
don't think for themselves and whenever
the Democrats want a vote they need the
black vote they just cry racism do you
speak for black and the black people go
into a trance and then going in and then
yeah yeah they reach for daddy why
eating kicking let me suggest to you
it's not really a new print no it is
that what can I are you open to hearing
why I don't think so isn't that a
plantation Hillary Clinton if you want a
black bow
he goes through the churches like
churches sure I don't feel no waste or I
feel like going on and back oh yeah
praise the Lord praise the Lord
okay so okay we got a vote next month
won't you trance here's why I don't do
that isn't that a plantation
okay so you've given us one example can
I take him in town
I don't know that particular example but
let me explain to you why I don't think
that that black Americans are so-called
in the tank for the Democratic Party
when Proposition 8 came up here in
California Democrats almost exclusively
supported legalizing gay marriage or
banning the outlawing of gay marriage
right although black Americans in
California tend to vote with Democrats
on that issue they didn't and to me that
says they're not voting for Democrats
because Democrats have in some way
co-opted them because as soon as there
was an issue that they disagreed with
Democrats on they voted the other way
well at that time they didn't believe
they had some sense of values they had
their own bodies been corrupted since
that time other of you might have
changed I guarantee you if they went now
and voted for and asked them to vote for
it they would go with the homosexuals I
hope so in the Democratic Party
I hope so they have been morally
bankrupt well I just rather call
homosexuals of God in there and they
corrupted churches and they have given
money to the preachers black preachers
and so now so what you're doing it with
values yeah okay so you probably get me
I'm going along I think you're right but
what you're doing is called a special
pleading in terms of logical fallacies
you made an umbrella statement and I
gave you a counter example which would
disprove it and then you introduced some
new reason why that's not a good counter
example that time they were not as
corrupt as they are today
there's no other the radical homosexual
saw that happen they're like oh no we
cannot have this and so whenever they
want to get the radical homosexuals and
that lines matter all of abortion people
the National Organization women who hate
men what makes everything
whenever they want to get their radical
agenda across them whether you shop lead
down if they say oh this is racism just
like the black people you're
discriminated against that's right what
does racist the probably hear that this
is incoherent they go the black people
here that is the only people love us so
we're gonna vote with them that's what
they've done to most blacks fears of the
racism made black people vote against
prop 8 is that we know the at that time
they were not in supportive they knew
that homosexuality or same-sex marriage
wrong okay because they feel has some
sense of value at that time but they
lost that change yes what about for my
daughter ro is coming back no thanks to
the great white hope and and speaking of
the great white hope what do you think
of the president now he's many almost
two years what's your impression of him
today
oh it's embarrassing in what way well
all of the countries that are
traditional allies are no longer even
including the United States and
important conversations because Trump
just doesn't understand anything he
embarrasses himself time and again it's
a real you know it's a it's it's a we
took approach this programs the fallen
state I feel like the office of the
White House is in a fallen state and so
that's why you say the president you you
know like it because of the reason just
gave me no you know I thought he was
doing right give me something real but
that that's all real I mean let's see
what give me as an Aryan or anything
you're happy with him about I there's
one thing I like okay which is that in
the in the tax plan that he did he
lowered did you follow the tax plan oh
well go he lowered the threshold at
which point medical expenses become
deductible so you not now can spend a
smaller amount on medical expenses
before they become deductible which i
think is a good thing
anything else not that I can think of
that's it yeah amazing and you haven't
paid attention to what he's done over to
that year and a half yeah over two years
almost two years yeah and so that's the
only thing that you can think of offhand
amazing are you for open borders No
oh are you for the wall going up no I
don't think it'll make a big difference
I think I don't well the overwhelming
majority of people who are undocumented
and are here are over staying visas
they're coming in from other countries
anyway so I think that the best way we
can cut down on undocumented immigration
would be to work with the countries
people are coming from to reduce
corruption and improve the economies I
think it'll be cheaper and I think it'll
be more effective amazing and so there
are a care of and of illegal aliens
coming now between three to four
thousand one hundred thousand I think
something like that are you happy that
when you turn on a TV and you see these
people coming I'm not for so I mean I'm
against crossing the border if you'll be
putting the wall up before they get
there so they can't cross we could make
it so that they're not even trying to
come over here if we actually worked
with the countries they're coming from
to improve the economy so it is a real
put up a wall around its borders with is
it wrong for doing that well wrong and
effective are two different things
so let's do both whether they were they
wrong we'll put it up a border very
different situation
have you been to Israel I have have you
gone to those areas I have survived I
mean I think that the main there's
there's a couple differences that that
are going on there I mean one is that
Arab Israelis are Israeli citizens and
what you're talking about there is like
a very specific security situation I
would still prefer that wall not be
necessary right but it's not the same
situation to me yeah so again I'm black
and flow funny some yes or knows was
Israel raw for putting up a border yes
or no it would be up to them to say Who
am I to say you're standing by our
borders I'm not saying it would be wrong
I'm saying it's not what I would do they
want to do it do it the board of that
Israel put up if they're effective I'm
not sure so all of a thing you dumb
wouldn't come to Israel if you want to
go to you know if that wall is the fact
you don't keep up with what's happening
is Israel I keep up with it I don't know
the specifics of how no I really don't
know
I don't believe it okay I won't accept
it Paul you do no but you won't say okay
and the reason you won't say because you
know that that wall is effective you
know they did the right thing to put it
up but you won't say it because that
means that no you admit this about is
redoing it no no you will have to admit
I'm speculating here if you put a wall
around a boy so you're not being artists
I'm speculative mo you for that do it do
I get to talk about okay I'm speculating
that in Israel it's a very different
situation to even get in the country so
you don't have in Israel in what's a
very small country the situation of
overstayed visas which are again in the
u.s. most people that are here illegally
are not physically crossing a border
you're very good well no it's a
different situation
no you're deviating they have a wall
there other countries who have wall and
common sense people know that you should
put a wall around your house if you have
strangers coming in uninvited and then
we have these people coming from
[ __ ] countries and we don't have no
idea who crossing the borders we could
have been lot and folks coming okay but
let's drugs and violent and then these
women are coming with these babies no
fathers we have to take care of those
baby let me ask you a question you say
oh no let's say you put up the white
rhodium just not hear about it I don't
believe it I can't believe it if Israel
puts up I'm sorry if if the US puts up
the wall and every person crossing by
land is stopped which is about 35%
you've still got the other 65% that are
here on overstayed visas and flying what
do you do about then we need to deal
with it okay how do you do we do
whatever it takes but how would you do
it I don't know I have no idea right now
but how do I know that wall is a grater
you don't know what else to do stop the
flow Bob put it up the wall yeah and
then we start cleaning up the mess
inside the home and I which is our
country and that's what Israel did and
we should do the same thing okay I'm
glad you did it it's the right thing to
do but if it's also right for my country
and I'm little surprised you want to
admit that because you know it's true no
that's I mean I think we just disagree
amazing
it's crazy to disagree the the children
of the lie were screaming at all about
the early Kaling and mothers okay
all your separating their mothers from
your children oh no don't do it do you
know do you agree with me that was drama
they didn't they don't care about the
illegal aliens the children or the
mothers I've seen no evidence that they
don't care about the children or the
mother really yeah where it's evidence
that they do care I'd tend to believe
people are good generally and I have no
reason to suspect that someone who
claims to care about the suffering of
others doesn't really care then why
don't we hear the same cry out or crying
when women inside this country commit
crimes they go to prison and the kids
are left behind I think why are they
saying it oh no separating the mothers
because incubate the alien women are
committed to cry about coming here yeah
you illegally in trying to get into our
country they care about that but they
don't care about the women who are
citizens of this country committing
crime and going to prison I just read a
very interesting piece about women's
prisons in the New York Times and it
does seem people care about that amazing
and you believe that they do care I have
no reason to doubt it yeah I want to ask
the great white hope more people working
now I believe I just saw a report 7.1 I
think million jobs are available now
they don't have people trained well
enough to take those jobs is that a good
thing that the president has done what
did he do bring bad jobs
hell I don't know matter how he's
brought them back is that a good thing
if you're going to claim he did it you
have to explain how is that a good thing
there to happen it something to their
jobs the question is what did he do to
bring the jobs well what he did is they
were good you identify what he did I
just told you man how do you know he did
it it's a good thing that he did in it
jobs are good I'm asking you what Trump
did do you think yesterday the elections
are coming up in November
yes do you think your Democrats garna
we're not a Republican I think the most
likely scenario is Democrats take the
house Republicans keep the Senate well
and why do you think the Democrats would
take the house because of the polling in
the House races come
to polling in Senate races you believe
in a polar generally speaking out did
you believe there when President Robert
running for president and all the polls
were saying that Hillary's gotta where
did he believe that well the national
polls said Hillary would win by about
three percentage points in the popular
vote and she did did you believe the
polls when they say that Hillary Clinton
was gonna win that's not what the poll
said they said nowhere now even Hillary
thought you cricket lie Hillary thought
he got away but that's a different
argument Justin did you believe that
they were gonna where did I believe who
was going to Democrat Oh crooked Hillary
I believe the polls that Hillary would
win the popular vote and she did but you
need Molina who become president I
thought it was it was certainly
plausible and likely sure and why did
you think that why did I think that no
why did you think that why didn't I know
why did you think that oh because of the
polls so you believe the polls that
Hillary Clinton will win the the polls
were accurate in that she won the
popular vote by three percent that's
what because of that you thought Hillary
Clinton will win right Jesse you're
interrupting me go ahead the the
national polls assess what the popular
vote difference would be they said
Hillary would win by about three percent
she did so did you believe that Hillary
Clinton will win as president I did and
I was wrong wrong oh that's what the
polls there yeah so why are you in a
poll i they didn't lie they weren't true
they just didn't assess the electoral
vote why are you believing in polls now
I have no reason to doubt the polls I
said yes you should
okay we'll deliver degree white hope I
got out here just a couple more
questions here so but just so I know do
you are you saying the Republicans will
keep the house I'm not sure but I have a
small feeling especially with what
happened with Josh Kevin or the attack
on him by the children of the lie okay I
think even moderates and independents
and Democrats who would normally not
vote for Republican I think they were
and especially now that Republicans
people who support the great white hope
doesn't talk on your chat okay you know
we see it with the representatives the
children are going to cafes and
restaurants and our poise and just
caring are right it's turning off a lot
of people a lot of decent people I guess
we'll see do you
believe that if happening I don't think
so not not I'm not seeing that now I
gotta ask you what is the man I'm sorry
what is the man I do politics not
dictionary are you a man I think so and
what is the man no thing right but a man
what is this what you do define words
yeah what is the man I don't do
definitions on my show I'm not the right
person to add it what that's so boring
do you know what it is do I know what a
man is when I hear the word man I think
of mankind like Homo sapiens and you
know what's the future of mankind
what don't feel badly if you don't know
what a man is because a lot of males
don't know what a man is okay you know
so you're not alone on this one okay
and these are some good male don't know
what a man is I gotta ask love what is
love
I don't do the dictionary definitions
you don't know so you do you know what
love is
ah I think you know love when you see it
and and what is it when you see it you
just know it you can't even put it into
words it's so ethereal amazing yeah I
gotta ask I know you need to make I want
you I know you here for the event as we
can tell the folks while you're in town
and whatever else you want to promote
I'm here I'll be at politican I will be
talking to people I will be talking
about politics I will be reframing bogus
questions which is something I like to
do I won't be doing dictionary
definitions at any of my events that's
the one thing if people are expecting
that I'm not doing any dictionary
definition so now I understand that
become most people shallow especially
intellectual and they're not really deep
thinkers hmm and dictionary definitions
are the most surface thing you have to
deal with real issues and real questions
like this in like it throws the
intellectuals off I agree because they
don't necessarily do it yeah we're not
gonna waste time they're defining
dictionary words so the polluted
colonists we can post is that the Los
Angeles Convention Center
you could buy ticket at politico.com I'm
going to be there on Sunday twelve new
and another time at on Sunday at 2 p.m.
Wow talking about the grief why hope I'm
having you yeah Wow and this is my
second year incredible
and Hazen and next week we went downtown
last a couple weeks ago now and we
filmed a [ __ ] walk you know the [ __ ]
walk is now a woman by the name of a
morose had this movement going on morosa
I'm a rose oh and she wants [ __ ] you be
accepted women who have stuck with a lot
of man okay just be flat how do you
define a lot of men like at what more
than one more than welcome yeah and so
she's trying to take the shame out of
being called a [ __ ] and women and so we
videotaped that and that is coming out
next Thursday is so amazing the [ __ ]
they feel amazing incredible you I slept
I'm sorry you like let's I don't know
any now you have a [ __ ] we're a [ __ ] I
don't think so would you date us led to
purge or it it's not a term I use
amazing my final question oh do you know
what a [ __ ] here's where you see one no
make sure you watch this let walk cut on
the pharmacy thank you
my final question did you have fun no no
listen I think that this is in in a
thousand years when the sociologists and
the Philosopher's try to figure out what
exactly happened in the United States
are right around this time this type of
conversation is going to be incredibly
informative for them so I'm glad to have
participated in it good man gonna think
wow Jess it was amazing and the
installation guy nice you're a nice guy
David thank you for coming there thank
you for having me I really do appreciate
thank you alright
and thank you all for tuning in and
don't forget to light follow tweet here
or comment and all that I get saw this
stuff check out our brand new saw on the
jessamine Peterson comm on my Instagram
you're doing songs now huh Facebook
Twitter you're saying are you planing to
call beta male you know what a beta male
is no check out the thong chase Trump
right alpha naught beta
see him with the toilet paper on his
shoe super alpha move huh
thank you I'll bet you do thank you